le plus dur reste à faire dans la vie on
ne s'est pas laissée par le facétieux de
devenir joueur professionnel ment pas il
va falloir qu'ils débattent encore
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus parce que je
pense que si venait faire la carrière de
café que les fait automatiquement mon
hiver loi qui fascine beaucoup jaune
pourrait-il des fourmis dans les jambes
au point de vouloir reprendre sa place
d'arrière latéral
heureusement non car voyez le résultat
de jeunes joueurs qui se joue du lieu de
supplice et son jeune fils qui à 20 ans
vient de signer son premier contrat
professionnel avec le fc grenoble
il n'imaginait pas que le nom de
djorkaeff revivre et dans le football
professionnel par l'intermédiaire de son
fils youri youri qui lui bien sûr
pour ce faire une aussi belle carrière
que possible
non je ne pense pas être meilleure si
demain on peut rentrer parce qu'on joue
pas les mêmes mots nous on joue pas à la
même époque
mais bon j'espère faire aussi bien c'est
moi le football est vraiment une grande
famille